[Music]
so when we think about what motivates
people maybe the first thing to think
about is what we think motivates people
and what don't we understand motivates
people and maybe the first
misunderstanding is about the pleasure
principle so we have this idea of we
have the right to pursue happiness and
we're trying to be happy and that's
really what we're pursuing happiness but
think about it what what gives you
happiness in a way that is observable
maybe sitting on the beach drinking
mojito or maybe sitting on the sofa
watching a sitcom but if you do almost
anything that is useful meaningful that
you take pride of it's not the same
things but imagine you have a whole life
of sitting on a on the beach drinking
mojito how how happy would that life be
so the first I think mistake is that we
pursue momentary happiness rather than
longer-term happiness so we do this the
things that will make us laugh out loud
today kind of not always laugh out loud
but you know kind of like that and we
don't do the things that are difficult
and complex and challenging but give us
a very different sense of happiness
think about something like running a
marathon you don't see anybody happy
like if you came is an alien and you
image people's brains and you looked at
your facial expression as they're
running a marathon you would say
somebody's punishing them like they are
paying for something terrible they've
done and this is how they're you know
paying their debt to society and it it
is it is kind of miserable but it's also
meaningful and create a sense of
achievement and so on so we're pursuing
momentary pleasure rather than truly
understanding the depth of what
happiness is or what meaning meaning is
and then the second thing is that we're
trying to figure out how we externally
motivate people and we have usually a
very simple equation that says
motivation equals money and if you're
not working hard enough doing something
I'm not just not paying you enough I'm
not not giving your bonus in the right
way
we just jigger around bonuses and
payment and we say oh let's change the
payment this way change payment this way
and give a slightly big bonuses here and
slightly big bonus there and we'll
create point systems for evaluation and
all kinds of things the beauty of human
nature is that lots of things motivate
us and sense of accomplishment and
achievement our title our connection to
work and connection the people at work a
competing with other people all of those
things motivated so we routed a
motivation equation we would write
motivation equals yes money is important
but so is achievement sense of progress
competition that adhara and the question
is how do we use all of them how do you
use all of them to to create motivation
and you know in physics people look for
the perpetual motion machine how do we
get energy from nothing right and
continue going and in motivation there
is something like that so imagine two
businesses in one of them the business
doesn't care about motivation in one of
them they care deeply in the first
business people are miserable and the
business is miserable and they're not
making lots of money in the second one
people could be happier management could
be happier and they could be much more
productive inefficient everybody wins
when we invest in deep motivation one of
the first experiments we did on the
question of meaning it wasn't like big
meaning was little mini and here is what
we did we got people to come to the lab
and we say would you like to build a
Bionicle and we'll pay you $3 for this
Veronica and people build it Bionicle we
took it we put it under their desk and
we say would you like to build another
one for 2 dollars and 70 cents if they
say yes we gave the next one and then
the next one for 30 cents less and less
and less diminishing wage until they
said stop no more right and we told all
of those people that when they finish
the task we'll take all the Bionicle
we'll break them into pieces and prepare
them for the next participant that was
that what we call the meaningful
condition it's not really meaningful but
it is meaningful compared to the next
condition in the next condition which we
internally call the cific condition it
started the same way we said to be
would you like to build a Bionicle for
$3 and they started doing it and they
finished we took it from them we kept it
on our on the desk on the desk and then
we said would you like to build another
one for 270 if they say yes they started
building the second Bionicle but as they
were building the second manacle we took
the pieces apart from the first Bionicle
so we got destroyed it in front of their
eyes and then we put it back in the box
and then this we said would you like to
build a third one for 30 cents less and
if they said yes we gave them back the
first one that they assembled we broke
and this way we continued back back and
forth now and we call this the sisyphic
condition because if you remember
Sisyphus from the mythology he was
sentenced to push a rock up the hill and
we almost go to the top the rock would
roll back and head to the same Hill and
the idea was it if there were different
hills right if you were just going over
different hills maybe he would felt some
progress but having to the same Hill
over and over was directly the depth of
demoralizing people and what happened
kind of a couple of interesting things
the first one is that people stopped
much faster in the sisyphic condition
the second one is we asked people how
much they enjoyed Legos in general and
we wanted to see whether there's a
correlation between how much they
enjoyed Legos and how much they
persisted in this task and what we saw
was that in the meaningful condition
there was a correlation people who loved
Legos did more Bionicles people who
didn't like Legos internally didn't like
so much in the sisyphic condition the
correlation was zero which means that we
have sucked away the joy of assembling
Legos because you see the people who
love Legos did not do any more than the
people who didn't somehow the joy of it
just went away the other interesting
insight from this study is with another
version of this experiment in which
people did not engage in building
Bionicles but we did this in business
school and we asked the students to
predict how other people would behave in
those two environments right so you say
okay you have an environment with more
meaning environment with less meaning
how many Bionicles will people build
differently in those two environments
and we paid people for the accuracy of
their predictions what happened
people predicted that the difference
will be in the meaningful condition
people would build more but they
predicted would be only one Bionicle
more so we understand that meaning
matters but we think it matters very
little in fact it mattered a lot people
build almost four more Bionicle so
there's a big a big gap and people don't
don't understand how how meaning is
important and if you think about it as a
manager actually as anybody if you're
trying to motivate people you could be a
schoolteacher you could be a parent
whatever it is if you're trying to
motivate people you have to understand
how big is meaning and if you think that
meaning has a very small affects you
would not invest much in it only if you
understand
how big and important it is you will
invest in it
[Music]